بدات نذر المواجهه المرتقبه مبكرا بين
الرئيس الامريكي ومجلس النواب بسبب زياره
الاولى يقوم بها جو بايد للحدود الجنوبيه
التي تعاني من مشكله تدفق المهاجرين
والمخدرات
رئيس مجلس النواب الردان انتقد وتوعد
بتحرك الجمهوريين نحو محاسبه لن تستثني
الرئيس ووزير الداخليه في مجلس النواب
بسبب خلق اخطر ازمه حدوديه في التاريخ
الامريكي بحسب تعبيره في وقت يرى فيه بعض
الديمقراطيين ان البلاد تعاني من نقص كبير
في الايدي العامله لجراء قيود صحيه فرضها
دونالد ترامب وتم الاعتراض عليها امام
القضاء
الحدود بين الولايات المتحده والمكسيك
ممتده على ثلاثه الاف ومئه كم على تلك
الحدود تم القاء القبض على رقم قياسي بلغ
مليونين و 200 الف مهاجر العام الماضي
ارسل البيض الى الكونجرس خطه لاصلاح
الهجره في اول يوم له في منصبه لكنها
تعثرت وسط معارضه من الجمهوريين في
الكونغرس الذين منعوا ايضا طلبه للحصول
على ثلاثه مليارات و500 مليون دولار
لتعزيز تطبيق الحدود
يحول الرئيس الامريكي من خلال زيارته تلك
اخماد الضجيج سياسيه وتخفيف التاثير
التحقيقات المقبله في الهجره التي وعد بها
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
الجمهوريون استخدموا باستمرار قضيه الحدود
ضد باين والقو باللوم عليه
يبدو ان اي حركه للرئيس الامريكي ستكون
تحت عدسه رصد مجلس النواب ذي الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه المعارضه عقبه تلو اخرى تنتظر
جو عبيد لن تبدا بازمه الحدود والمهاجرين
ولن تنتهي عندها عصام عبد السلام العربيه